All right. I got green. Hey.
Come to me.
Where are you? You know where I am.
How am I supposed to get there.
The old Irish way.
You're still Irish, aren't you?
I'm Irish. Enough, honey.
That your office.
Come off it being a crutch.
But I'll sip whisky and stare at the stars
with you.
Oh, thank you.
I want you to take me out on a date.
A date, huh?
And eight. With dinner.
Maybe we can go to that music festival after
all.
But I'm way too tired to analyze exactly what
it is that you want. But I know it ain't a
date. It's no test.
Just a date. Lord knows you can afford it.
And we're in the same three pairs of jeans
and jacket for a f***ing decade.
Yeah.
Probably got more money than me.
No.
Money's the one thing I don't have.
You get paid every week, don't you?
Mm. So what do you spend your money on?
You're keeping a sweet little place in town
for a Saturday night.
Jesus Christ. Why is it that your mind always
stops the first thing that you should never
do?
What's wrong with that?
I was a man. I'd buy an apartment complex
and I'd fill it with buxom little bunnies.
I'd start on the first floor Friday and end
up on the roof by Sunday.
I'm serious.
What do you spend your money on?
Beth. It's a nice night.
Let's not ruin it with truth.
Tell me.
I spent $22,000 on my mom's headstone.
Stands about as tall as me.
Marble. I got the guy to etch your face into
it. I spent 30.
Am I my little brother's.
It stands a little bit taller.
I don't know. I guess I want him to be a
little closer to heaven. At best, money that
I ever spent was 5,000 to a grave Digger and
Forsyth.
What did you pay him for?
He dug out my father.
Gave me his bones.
I drove from there all the way to North
Dakota, throwing him out the f***ing window.
I remember the stories of heaven and hell in
church. Lies a lot of it.
I think heaven's right here.
So is Hell.
One person can be walking the clouds right
next to someone enduring eternal damnation.
And God is the land.
Don't say it. It doesn't mean anything on
our roof. Under stars like a bunch of
f***ing hippies.
Hey, tell me. Tell me when it saves me.
Okay.
I won't say it.